can you explain George and Kellyanne
Conway to me I don't know [ __ ] I respect
the fact that your father's kept her on
and but her husband I find hateable just
because like this is your wife and
you're just you think you're just you're
okay on some level agree with him how do
they stay married I don't think so but
uh you know listen I'm not gonna apply
on people's individual relationships but
again imagine imagine the husband of a
high-ranking left-leaning official was
doing that they destroy him right you
know this would be the second I met you
know he's bitter he didn't get a job in
the administration that he wanted she
did she's now the rock star that's out
there you know doing a good job and he's
pissed but like you know where are the
feminists like attacking him no no well
he's attacking Trump so he gets a total
pass on the fact that he's making a
really tough for her to be able to do
her actual job that she signed on for
you know this is a grown woman that's
deciding to do this and she's good at it
so again it's one of those things like
now this guy's the hero cuz he's part of
the resistance I mean give me a break
right I can't believe it when I see it
like heat whether or not they like you
know James Carville and his wife would
they both in our opposite ends of the
spectrum is a liberal and a Republican
they're publicly and he's like so
publicly against the man that her job is
to publicly support I mean we talk about
it all the time it's the craziest thing
I've ever seen yeah no I'm with you on
that one
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]